[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is a girl that I've
been following for a while now she also
wears the color red a lot she has red
hair her name is Gabby covalenko she is
really big on Instagram and YouTube and
it's growing very quickly and she is
she is 22 just about 23 years old and
when you start to hear her talk you're
like wow where the heck does that come
from she is you know she's just one of
those Unique Individuals that just gets
it she just understands how things work
and so she works in the area of energy a
lot and I'm gonna read how she describes
her work she's a transformational
thought leader who teaches a
pro-consciousness approach to personal
development and mindful living for those
of you who've listened to a lot of the
interviews I've done you'll understand
this is the stuff that I ask a lot of
questions about him so fascinated with
so we talked about the Matrix we talked
about Consciousness and Enlightenment
and the ego what the universe is and
then what the universe is and how you
can upgrade your life so that you become
a match to the reality that you want and
essentially that's what it's all about
right and it's not about she says a
beautiful line I'm just going to call it
at the beginning pain is inevitable but
that suffering is a choice yes there are
things that aren't easy but suffering is
your choice how you can align yourself
and see the events from a higher
perspective to have more peace about it
hit the Subscribe button I really really
appreciate that it shows me that you
enjoy the content hit the bell for
notifications and as always
thoughts in the comments I can't wait to
hear this one I wore red because well
it's my favorite color and I was almost
gonna put this on yesterday I did a
couple episodes yesterday and I was like
no tomorrow I wear red
um but I do have a theory that days have
a color and like I noticed this in
particular like going to the gym which I
know we can totally talk about
um but but generally speaking even at um
I went to a golf tournament the other
day and everyone was wearing green and
even my friend was like Wow everyone's
in green and so I just have a theory
that days have a color so I wonder since
you work all in the sphere of energy and
frequency how what do you think of that
and how does that play into energy and
frequency
I think there's a lot right there to
unpack first of all I think we are all
tied into the collective Consciousness
so that's one massive concept that
influences the way that we perceive
reality and perceive ourselves there's
also nothing That Is Random so many of
us experience you know certain color
that comes to mind and everything that
we do I believe plays into an
intentional construct within our own
minds so if we wake up and all of a
sudden we're drawn to Red there's
probably a reason why we're feeling that
that maybe an internal mood a state that
we're wanting to project openly and it
could be an emotion that we're maybe
repressing that we're wanting to reveal
outwardly or maybe it's something that
the collective Consciousness is going
through so maybe it's a collective mood
or an energy that a lot of people are
feeling which is maybe why we both
decided to wear red today but I noticed
you tend to match with the people that
you you know do podcasts you tend to
wear the same color so maybe you're
synced up with your guest that you have
on the day I don't know but it's very
interesting and I think it's part of
just being very in tune to the current
state so a lot of us when we really pick
up energy and are perceptive of the
different micro changes that we're
feeling deep down viscerally then we'll
start to express ourselves accordingly
because of that so it sounds like you're
very attuned to energy and you're just
flowing with you know the day and the
moments that arise
actually that's that for me
um
like I don't feel people's feelings but
I can I'm aware of them
my feeling comes in the in the in in the
area of of frequency
so and patterns generally but um but
frequency for sure so even in my house
like I have three EMF reducing devices
in my house like I took Wi-Fi on my
bedroom I want to live somewhere with
more like a little bit further out of
town somewhere that there's more nature
like I feel very sensitive to frequency
and so I sit that that then also
transcends into people too of course
um I mean not of course but definitely
because we are so such energetic beings
and have so much power
um in that way and so with people I can
also sense that so if I can feel that
there's something off and there's
Discord and there's not a match in their
energy and the way they present then I
also get
um
well I I immediately know something's
wrong it also plays into when I meet
someone or I'm meeting people and I
don't have to be Danica Patrick the race
car driver
um which is just a role essentially like
I know how to slot into that it is me
but it's just this part of me and so
when I don't have to be that and I can
just kind of relax and chill I'm
actually really quiet because I'm
totally trying to see if the way that
people present is the same as the
frequency that they're emitting and I
didn't know that I was doing that until
probably like a two years ago or so
um but that's what I'm doing I'm trying
to see if there's coherence and um and
then how I want to deal with it do I
want to just not talk to them do I want
to totally dive in do I want to question
them to some degree and kind of prove
them out a little bit right there and
then there which is a fun way to go but
not always the nicest you're an empath
it's very clear that you're very attuned
to your environment and a lot of us
empaths we have this ability to be very
plugged into our surroundings and the
the downside of that is we can become
very hyper Vigilant to other energies
and other frequencies at play so I've
noticed there is a dark side of the
empath which plays into the collective
there's a lot of empaths that are too
hyper aware of their environment to the
extent that they start to falsify
themselves because they're responding to
the environment when they don't
necessarily have to for example I have
clients that come to me they're super
empaths they feel like they're always
absorbing the energies around them so
for example like a nurse who walks into
a room she feels her patient to the
extent that she becomes her patient she
starts to merge with her field she knows
what they're going through she feels
their emotions that can become very
toxic and very difficult to always carry
that burden of being plugged into the
environment so what can we do about that
I have blown people away because I told
them that though you're an empath and
you can feel the field around you you
can also shut out the ability to
constantly let that field penetrate your
own right so there's a big difference
between just taking in information and
being able to process that information
and create a barrier in between yourself
and the environment so what you can do
is actually imagine that you can receive
all the information
eternally that exists outside of you but
also know how to filter It Out by just
deciding that you have a boundary around
you
so with energy it's very easy to learn
how to filter it out Simply by
understanding that your own field is
determined by everything that you decide
to imbue it with it's an intention
exactly we can decide to be this
penetrating field that takes in
everything around us including the
toxicity including the low frequencies
or we can decide to keep that barrier
and when we set the energetic intention
to have like a force field around us a
force field of light and love and our
own you know state of being then we get
to predetermine what our field contains
so I told that nurse that she no longer
has to be dragged down by these
frequencies around her and she's like oh
my gosh I could actually experience
freedom because this means that I don't
have to be the receiver of all that
information and truly that's what we are
we're a receiver of information right
we're an antenna we're all these
energetic vessels but we all to varying
degrees and capacities can take in
information and know what to do with it
so many of us we struggle because we're
constantly taking information and think
that we don't have any free will we
don't have the ability to filter out or
set that boundary which is why I think
one of the most important elements of
self-love is being able to set that
boundary it's knowing who you are and
knowing who you are not so though you
are a Danica the receiver of information
who gets to feel energy all the time you
get to decide who is going to leech
energy into your field who are you going
to share energy with and that toxicity
you can just decide to not allow in
that's the most loving thing you can do
for yourself and it's vital when you're
an empath to know these boundaries to
know the standards of the the energy you
want to allow into your reality which
relates to relationships all
interactions Dynamics and even receiving
you know psychic influences so it's
interesting I know people who live in
New York City for example and they say
that I can't be in the city for too long
because it starts to weigh down on me
some people they feel like they get
tired they feel too much of the you know
high frequency input that puts them in a
gamma brainwave State and all that and
they feel like they need to get out at
the same time I know of shamans who live
in New York City and who say that this
frequency actually uplifts me so the
high frequencies are putting my brain
into a super-tuned state where I get to
harmonize I get to feel alive I get to
feel the masculine energy of the city
actually put me into a state of balance
and puts me into like a wired state to
achieve in life so it depends on how we
actually perceive the role of those
frequencies around us and even when it
comes to Red you know I wear red often I
decided to get my hair red as I went
through some personal shifts in my life
I just felt really in resonance with
that energy but then I have people leave
me comments all the time that are like
that red is a low frequency thing and
that's your root chakra and that's not
harmonic or spiritual
show how exactly right it's just a
really subjective perception of the
energy and the frequency and there is no
good or bad energy it's all just energy
and every frequency plays into a you
know an infinite Spectrum so it just
depends on the meaning that we assign to
it okay well then that plays into a
question that I was thinking about and
then you said nothing's good or bad so
I've always been really curious about
anxiety and like how people really
really deal with like debilitating
levels of anxiety
um and I had not experienced anxiety
well I feel like anxiety is a little
like an orgasm if you're not sure if you
have anxiety you don't right it's kind
of like an orgasm and then it once you
experience real anxiety you go wow I
can't choose a good thought I'm feeling
my heart is racing I feel my stomach is
clenched up like there's like a whole
visceral experience and an inescapable
thought path and
um and so I had never experienced it
until a few years back and I had a few
episodes and I think I've only happened
like once since so I probably had like
four different times I recognized I
think it was even like the second third
one like maybe even all of them is what
I'm what I'm thinking well it's what I
feel like is true to me is that all of
them weren't mine
I was but I don't absorb People's Energy
so I don't understand why it happens
sometimes is it because it's so so
strong that it comes into my field and
that I that I actually gets through or
or could it be like
something else another an energy or
entity sort of attaching in a way like
could this be more than just another
human
do you see what I'm saying so what was
the source of the anxiety
during the different episodes
um the source of it was someone else
that had to do with relationship every
time it's had to do with Relationship
Challenge
did it feel like you couldn't Express
Yourself was there an anxiety with being
yourself or speaking your truth to that
person it was not knowing the truth it
was feeling like
questioning the truth feeling like I was
getting information that was not that
was hurtful but not
um but not knowing if it's true right
because is it intuition is it just a
story I'm telling myself so this comes
down to do you really trust your
feelings or are your feelings a source
of your anxiety so a lot of us we
experience anxiety surrounding feeling
something that we don't know how to
express when our own truth is something
that would come into conflict with
because we think mentally that we need
to act in a certain way in order to
preserve ourselves in a certain
situation
this is something that so many people
struggle with they feel one thing
there's an internal reality but in order
to express that means to go against
everything that they have already
externally manifested so for example
you're in a relationship that doesn't
feel good to you but yeah you wake up
every morning and you do your best to
put on a show to preserve that
relationship so you tell your partner
certain things you deprive yourself of
your own needs you say things that are
in contradiction to your truth in order
to just keep that going so what are we
actually doing at the end of the day we
are lying to ourselves keeping ourselves
in the dark in order to maintain some
external reality that we think is going
to suit us but does it really usually
that ends up resulting in anxiety and
depression and suppressed feelings and
personal mistrust and in quieting our
inner voice because we don't believe
that it deserves to be heard
right that is a really deep reality when
we're in such dramatic contrast to our
higher self's awareness and our own
personal truth that the system goes
anxiety is telling us that we need to
pay attention to ourselves and yet we
see it and we try to silence it even
more we think of anxiety as something
that we need to just run away from but
similar to pain it's a reality that
means you need to listen more to
yourself a lot of people approach pain
in that way too they think that if I'm
in pain you know I need to try to shut
those feelings down try to do something
to run away from myself when in truth
it's the exact opposite thing it's your
self-consciousness of your internal
system begging you for attention wanting
recognition wanting you to actually go
within and accept those feelings and
somatic experiences but what do we often
do we just keep going into the world and
try to distract ourselves we want to try
the next thing to run away from our own
truth and everything we know to be real
for us deep down that's the most
degrading thing we can do
well the last time it happened I
basically
re responded within it probably was
discomfort for like 30 or 40 minutes and
then I ended up sending a message being
like um I'm having like a somatic
experience my body is freaking out I
know it's not I I said it doesn't feel
like mine I don't know what's going is
something going on is there information
in the field coming to me that is not
yet in my conscious awareness that lands
in the subconscious or in the energy
body that tells me something that is not
yet arrived up here in the brain well
really they're all entangled right your
soul your heart's Consciousness your
higher self that knowing that's in the
field basically you know who you are at
your core you could feel that by
connecting to Your Heart by just being
with yourself feeling that information
but it's also something that is in the
field because you could say that in the
holographic field around us there exists
really a true version of us the soul
that is non-local so you could be
picking up that information right as
you're entangling with your higher self
that's coming through intuition through
subtle cues which a lot of people wonder
what's the difference between then fear
and intuition if intuition can come in
the form of fear when we feel like we're
out of alignment with our higher self
so that's something to really look for
too because fear in the mind is usually
the opposite of intuition but something
that feels like fear because when you're
in your heart you feel out of alignment
with something you're dealing with
externally could be the intuitive cue
you need to go back within and connect
to that source of Truth which is either
internal or you could say external but
not relating to the people around you
that are you know trying to get you out
of alignment so this is really a
question of whether or not we want to
come back home and know who we are and
do what's right for us to connect with
that frequency of just pure integrity
and and Truth this seems like the answer
for everybody would be yes right I feel
like everyone would say I want to know
the truth I mean I don't think
everyone's prepared to deal with what
that means but I think everyone would so
what blocks that like what is it that
doesn't allow someone to step into a
deeper knowing and sense of Truth and
sense of self it would be the harsh
reality that everything that you're
experiencing now is due to you depriving
yourself of that truth once you step
into the truth you have to be accepting
of everything that you've done that is
in opposition to it
and so we go into this cognitive
dissonance State we go into the state
that we have to now be responsible for
everything in our reality that we
dislike and we have to take ownership
over these parts of us that we've kept
in the dark and we've denied Our Truth
which turns into our shadow and it turns
into the repression of all the emotions
that really are deep down telling us
what our personal truth is saying and so
externally speaking when it comes to
things happening in the world which we
often you know turn our attention away
from the same thing holds true we don't
want to see the reality because that
would mean accepting everything that is
also teaching us the deeper lessons
about ourselves
and we don't want to harmonize because
that means having to reconcile the parts
of us that we have not seen we have not
understood and so this is what you know
makes people go into these repeating
cycles of constantly manifesting the
same situations dealing with the
expression of their Shadow because
they're all the time just trying to
deprive themselves of that truth and
it's easier for people to sort of live a
lie than to look in the mirror and to
figure out what is it that's causing the
expression of these things that I
dislike
but then that means not trying to run
away from them anymore
so to truly embody the truth means
having to meet everything that you've
been wanting to suppress it's wanting to
see everything in your reality as an
expression of you which could be the
most difficult part because we want to
say that you know certain things we're
not responsible for some things are just
you know part of suffering and the
universe's test for us it's a matter of
how do we respond to that and do we want
to respond truthfully or keep ourselves
in this Loop of just believing that the
universe is working against us because
truthfully might mean the end of a
relationship the end of a friendship the
end of a job the end of where you live
the end of how you go about your life
certain habits and hobbies you have and
you know as I say so often and I had to
say to myself in the past is that your
new life is going to cost you your old
one you know exactly and and that's a
hard thing for people to and I think
there's there's some there's a deep
attachment that people have to I can
feel it in the energy of like
um like Joe dispenza's book title like
breaking the habit of being yourself but
in this sort of uh changing of
Personality or like becoming someone
different it's like there's a real
loyalty to the Persona that someone has
created for themselves that they don't
want to abandon there's like a certain
um they feel like that's the wrong thing
that that's not somebody loving them
just the way they are or they feel like
it is somehow the like just not um like
that that it's an abandoning of the
personality
right it's a coping mechanism really
it's a defense mechanism oh kind of like
during Coco's story they tell you to go
like oh no this is who you are right
which is the most pervasive image of who
we are we start to have a love affair
with this ego because we think that it's
what we need to sustain our sense of
self because what's really what's true
deep down if we keep going deeper and
deeper past those layers of falsity and
you know self-image things that we
fabricate in order to believe that that
is who we are is a totally fluid essence
at the core of it is no Essence at all I
mean everything is just pure energy pure
potentiality pure Consciousness so when
it comes down to that infinite potential
of ourselves we want to fragment it we
want to bring it into some kind of
constructs that we believe make us more
relatable more appreciable more loved
all the while this is something that we
developed when we were still so young
that we didn't have a sense of identity
and so we learned to take these mental
constructs and turn them into ego
constructs and you're so right like
personality is something that could be
completely fluid except we don't want
that to be because we think that it's
unsafe to go into the world in a fluid
way and to just meet the demands of life
without being necessarily
fixed in our own identity
so consistency is something that I feel
like
the ego or in this Human Experience we
tend to lean into right we want to make
sure that we're safe in whatever way
that is through personality disorders
through the the hobbies and habits we
have the friends we keep the
relationships we attract but it doesn't
always mean it's just something good
it's just consistency so what challenges
are inherent to this reality
that we are in
and is that even true are there certain
things that is there anything inherent
or is this whole thing transitory and we
can shift and transcend it into
something completely different
called The Human Experience
right the inherent nature of it is that
we were born into a third dimensional
construct where we believe that we need
to be submitting to this construct
and so when we get into the spiritual
sense of you know wanting to transcend
wanting to Enlighten wanting to become
the fifth dimensional Consciousness we
can come into an awareness of what it
means to live outside of the box outside
of the Matrix Game which means learning
to see outside of the program but to
transcend that isn't necessarily to not
exist within it so for as long as we're
here we're existing within the Matrix
right within the third dimensional
reality so what our Consciousness knows
is that there's constantly these
boundaries that we're up against we're
up against boundaries of time which
remind can recognize but we know that
time is also transcendental in nature
but we have to learn how to work with
those constructs just like we have to
learn to integrate Duality Duality is a
construct within the third dimensional
Consciousness we know that everything
has a plus and minus positive negative
charge right that's not something that
we can transcend if we know love we're
also going to know pain if we know
sadness we're also going to know
happiness we have to learn to experience
and love that balance so that's inherent
to us but there is something very
pervasive too being within the Matrix
and wanting to conform to it that is
what the collective mind tends to do
people tend to be as one with the herd
they want to do the same thing that
everybody else does there's this
mentality that you know we need to
believe what everyone else believes and
so it's very difficult to learn how to
transcend when we look around everyone's
doing a certain thing and we can see
this Collective Consciousness playing
into all historic Trends everything from
you know fashion to food to the latest
diet to exercise Trends people are
constantly playing into some Trend
created by someone who wants us to think
and feel in a certain way and when we
don't doubt that we're always going to
be doing what everyone else does in The
Matrix playing a game fulfilling some
role and not really knowing who we are
because we're just adapting to the
concept of life within the Matrix when
we start to recognize that this is the
Matrix Game and we're a unique
individual that really exists outside of
the Matrix we were born to come into
here to recognize that this is what's
happening but really all the world's a
stage for us to recognize who we are and
learn what role do we really want to
embody is it this person who is just
operating by a script written by
somebody else or perhaps there was
someone who can recognize this game for
what it is and learn to operate outside
of it so when we do that when we step
into that mentality of true awareness
and Awakening then there becomes a
reality where we exist outside of the
Matrix what does that mean it comes
through in discernment in being able to
see okay certain things might have been
taught to me told to me but I don't need
to conform to those mental boundaries
and when you can exist outside of the
minds makeup and the mind's Matrix of
its own there are different constructs
which come into play you can start to
see that time is Transcendental you see
the soul is Transcendental and more
importantly you see that your entire
identity is Transcendental that you
chose this embodiment in order to learn
yourself through these different
situations interactions people and you
chose your parents and you chose your
upbringing and all these things that you
believed existed outside of your free
will because within the Matrix
programming you thought that you didn't
choose any of it but in reality from an
eternal perspective your soul wanted
this experience in order to understand
itself more fully so operating from that
mindset gives you an ability to expand
even more and to think about how can I
design this game how can I actually
embody what Unity Consciousness means
which is that I'm not separate from the
Matrix at all the Matrix conforms to my
own perception of it which means that
you as a soul have the ability to
understand that you are a fractal of
source Consciousness if everything is
just Consciousness then Consciousness
created The Matrix in order to make the
illusion of it very real to make people
wonder can I exist outside of it and
what is all this even for and when we
get to that point we can really see how
there is no ego at all and all of these
disorders and different issues that
people are dealing with are really just
aspects of you not knowing that you
don't have to conform to The Matrix
which means you don't have to conform to
your past you don't have to conform to
what your mind tells you you are you
don't have to look to the media and
believe everything that you were told
you can really start to believe that you
are a free Sovereign being governed by
the universal one and you can take that
Consciousness into a completely new
experience and just start to play with
it and existing in that reality where
you are the Mind yours one with the
cosmic mind and a higher intelligence
brings you this truth that really there
is no attachment other than what you
decide to attach yourself to
and that's a game changer because then
we can operate with love with freedom
with virtue and dignity and really know
that we are the creator of this
experience so why not make it the most
fluid harmonious experience that we can
which really frees the ego and it gives
us a new dimension of perception where
we're not clingy and hung up on these
things that have happened to us and
we're much more focused on how can we
optimize how can we bring into this
world what we want to see in it and
that's really being kind of as one with
reality as opposed to in opposition to
it so are you saying that everything in
the Matrix like there's the Matrix or
these or these dualities polarities are
aspects but
you're not of them I mean because they
they feel like they're very real it's
completely real if we can perceive it it
is real we can't just say that it's all
an illusion or we can also say that all
dualities are as real as non-duality
both truths are the truth if we can
start to see how truth is really the sum
of all truths we can get closer into
what that fifth dimensional
Consciousness is exploring but since
we're still third dimensional beings
everything that appears to be real for
us is real which is why we can't negate
any perspective we can't say that
someone's wrong and someone's right
everyone's right in their own way which
means that the only way to truly tap
into truth is to see how integration or
that summing up of our perspectives
brings us closer to the reality of
Oneness so masculine feminine exists in
order for us to explore these
fundamental differences in charge and
polarity in our third dimension if we
zoom into like the or zoom out into the
Universal Mind those polarities really
cease to exist everything is just one at
that level but that wouldn't be very
interesting for the purpose of exploring
Consciousness and knowing what it means
to contrast to experience differences
for a woman to know what it means to
meet a man and to experience the
differences in their own Fields Source
had to differentiate into all these
fragments in order to learn what
combination means to understand the
merger of divine Consciousness is there
some kind of overlay that's
testing Us in some kind of way or is
this merely
um vibration and frequency
morphing and intersecting with things
and it's as it kind of morphs perhaps
the the test gets more intense until
there's a lesson and then there's a
shift in the frequency and then you you
know like do you see what I'm saying is
this are there tests from another level
of Beyond us an overlay that's affecting
us or is this merely all we're all it's
all one field of frequency and we're
just kind of waving in and out of our
own little area
well I think they're both true really
true Everything has to exist on some
kind of Continuum which means that even
what we perceive to be the past is part
of the future right they're both
entangled which means that the higher
Dimensions might just be higher frame
rates of Consciousness we're at a lower
frame rate so which means we can't
perceive the truth at those higher frame
rates it's just like somebody who's like
super awakened and super aware and
knowledgeable could really regurgitate
this information very quickly they could
see it fast because they're responding
based on their own brain's ability to
just to be with it so it's very fast for
them I mean while someone who's on a
slower frame rate of Consciousness we
could say is just observing the reality
at only their limited degree of
perception
so they can't see all the waves they
can't see all the frequencies which is
also why very literally people who are
more plugged in who access those higher
States Of Consciousness they are more
attuned to the whole spectrum of
frequencies they are more of the empaths
they can feel more they could see more
which is why psychedelic substances you
know make us also more ensuing to the
point that we can see at those different
like through the veil we could see the
different colors we can see the
hallucinatory experiences even without
the psychedelics through our own mind's
eye through the pineal gland through
connecting to the scalar field and
picking up that information like an
antenna which means you're really just
raising your frequency to the point that
you are operating at that higher
dimensional level even here on third
dimensional plane so maybe that's what
it takes for us to transcend it's
understanding how can we unlock the door
through our own Consciousness in the 3D
in order to understand how to how do we
even end up in the 5D plus to begin with
what if we if this was the first step
what if the higher dimensions are really
our future what if that's what it took
for Consciousness to learn how to build
the latter in order to access its
infinite potentiality kind of like a
kindergartner going through you know an
adult in life having to go through the
stages of awareness and disintegration
and wars and fighting and polarities and
then you know eventually merging into
the infinite one again it's all
happening at the same time
simultaneously this beautiful Divine you
know game
that's coming back to the same truth of
Oneness I kept thinking of a story when
you said frame rates
um uh of eating an edible uh THC edible
for one of the first times and I was
cracking up and I'm like I'm missing
frames and that's all I kept saying I
was like I'm missing frames and and it's
like you know no really like it's like
I'm seeing like life and then all of a
sudden I miss a few frames and then it
kind of comes back and I feel like
there's just like missing frames but
that is how it's working right like it's
just explain more about that go go
further into frame rates and and how
that plays into our perception of
reality yeah we could say that when we
were born we had like a very slow frame
rate we couldn't really understand too
much we were just observing and waiting
for the experience to fill us with the
ability to perceive it which is why
we've taken information very fast and
we're still you know little kids we're
very observant and just ready to
understand the reality around us
and through the programming eventually
we get to the point where we can observe
reality at a certain frame rate which
tends to be kind of a status quo the
collective Consciousness level which is
a lot of people just taking information
selectively based on what they are given
and that's a very kind of modified
ability to perceive at large when we
start to ask deeper questions when we
start to come into alignment with
ourselves and like you said even being
able to discern between fear and having
interactions tell us that there's a
higher self maybe or possibly a
different reality than the one that
we're experiencing that exists
internally or outside of us that puts us
in the position to tap into those higher
frame rates of Consciousness when we
start to have more information coming in
when we start to listen the intuition
that can flood us is also us being able
to connect to those higher frame rates
of Consciousness so it's really just
being able to perceive that reality
exists on this kind of accordion that
consists of different frequencies
different levels different paradigms and
all of us are existing in a paradigm of
our own but we can always change the
frame rate if we decide that we're
curious and we want to learn more and we
want to receive more answers us just
setting that energetic command opens up
our field to receive more information
and more clarity what it takes is often
such a subtle cue just deciding that
we're ready or deciding that we want to
change or deciding that we're ready to
be more conscious and we don't want to
live within this kind of a matrix trap
that many people find themselves in but
think that they're trapped which just
creates the trap for themselves the
truth is we are free and there was never
kind of a box to begin with so thinking
outside the box is realizing that the
box is entirely an illusion
and so you can exist whatever frame rate
you want to you can be as free as you
want to but we so often believe that
because everybody else is limited we
have to exist in limited Paradigm which
is ultimately the thing that we need to
disintegrate is this notion of stuckness
and being constricted by some construct
that is outside of us
so where what do we become next
we can become as one with everything
which is the most kind of transcendental
awareness that we could have I mean of
course there's a self the reality of the
self can't be ignored we came in here in
order to experience who we are to know
that we're we have something unique to
bring into the world we have our own
gifts our own talents our own desires
when we start silencing those things we
just become like everyone else when we
come into this reality we could be
anyone that we want to be and we're
truly is one with the all
then a whole new reality begins to
awaken within us we might start changing
our job we might start doing things
completely differently like you said
changing our relationships find
ourselves surrounded by completely new
people and situations because we just
plug into that true source of Who We Are
and really there is no ego at the core
the ego is just the chosen identity so
the self is something that is really
magical it's what the soul is
characterized by and it's who we are at
our core so to tap into that
authenticity means that we're actually
doing what we're meant to be doing here
which is arguably the reason why we're
actually here we must have some innate
purpose and a reason why we chose to
embody this physicality in order to you
know experience this entire creation or
something to learn there has to be a
deeper lesson and when we start asking
ourselves you know really why are we
experiencing this Why Us instead of why
is this happening to us why is this
happening for us we can start to see
Life as a gift given to us and chosen by
us to create the most potentiality we
can start to play we can start to you
know curiously explore different
possibilities like you are such a great
example of someone who just asked these
deeper questions and you know is now
experiencing a totally different reality
than you once were wow could you ever
imagine when you were a race car driver
that you'd be doing this today I mean
somebody people have asked like have you
always been into this or your interviews
seem very deep is this new and I'm like
no like it's not but there was never a
time space and a place for it like since
probably from
2015-ish on but really got going more in
2017 I retired in 18.
um I mean it is part of what what pushed
the retirement I think for me or you
know leaving that behind and
um was that I just wasn't syncing with
my environment as much I was feeling how
uncomfortable it was for me it just the
energy of the people the environment
just it just wasn't comfortable as
comfortable anymore and so when I sort
of Let It Go and Let it Be whatever it
was going to be it it's it left and
um but I think about the way that I
think now and the things that go through
my head now and I'm like
I don't think about
my brain doesn't work even close to the
way it used to like the thoughts that go
through my head all day every day I
would say they must be and I'm just
trying to give my old self a little
credit
um of a little staying power but um
because again I'm attached to some
degree to that personality right
um maybe 10 of the same but maybe five
percent of the same but the rest of it
is totally different totally new and you
know we really operate much more like a
like a computer than anything right we
don't have to be the same thing we were
we neuroplasticity and reprogramming the
way that we think is
um is completely our and within our
control so why has that been a veiled
sort of Truth to us why why is it that
why is it that everything is coming
through so much now and I was just
thinking a couple minutes ago about
talking about time we're talking about
reality and we're talking about
Transcendence to some degree and so it's
like and frames per minute frames per
second and like the framework that we
see the the speed of frames and like how
time and where we are in the universe
and what's happening feels like it's
very accelerated right now so maybe the
question to go to because there was a
lot in there is what is happening
energetically with the planet right now
if we're going through a massive upgrade
which is something that has happened and
you know history sort of loops on itself
just like timed us so periodically we
have to go through these sort of
recalibration cycles and moments these
pivotal periods when we get to uh I see
it as a critical mass point when there's
too much of the same old there's too
much of a build up of certain
certain energies certain certain themes
is going on in the collective and there
has to be a breakdown of those recurring
patterns and Cycles there has to be a
reboot an opportunity for people to come
into alignment with something completely
different the collective doesn't really
want to be experiencing the same thing
just like energy is always shifting and
moving it's entirely fluid like
everything else right even in nature we
see these Trends and themes occurring
all the time there can't be a build up
of something ecosystems eventually
transform in some ways you know animals
move there's always some kind of dynamic
motion happening so the same thing
occurs at the cosmic level at every
level of the organism up to the
collective consciousness
right so we are going through some kind
of time of change which is forcing us to
look more into that Duality that's at
play more at the individual level and
then bridging that into the collective
mind which is something that happened
you know clearly with the pandemic so
many people were forced to look within
when they ended up at home which is a
very uncomfortable reality to experience
but also taught so many people about
that truth that there is a difference
between just living the life that we
thought that we were supposed to live
and entering a state of forced isolation
or maybe that's really just coming home
to who we really are which took a lot of
people into the transition period do you
want to keep keep doing what you've been
doing or do you want to live a
completely different reality on that
point it's really up to you the choice
is apparent
so
collectively generally
on this planet there's an upgrade
happening but is there
potential within the individual to
decide which to go a different direction
meaning extend
raise your frequency or can they
actually go the other way
or is it staying static and then the
contrast becomes more dramatic
totally choice you can always evolve or
devolve at any time
and that's really that's where you're
currently at that might not seem to be a
choice but usually it's when it doesn't
seem to be a choice that you're actually
devolving or you're just staying
stagnant but if you can see that there
is choice at play you can make different
choices on a day-to-day basis and it's
in these micro adjustments that you make
even just mentally being able to free
yourself from feeling like there's no
ability to to choose differently it
comes down to this sense and a lot of
people are struggling because they
believe that there is no free will which
is something very you know deep we can
argue about this it's a bit of a paradox
in itself because there is and isn't
free will just like everything there has
to be the two sides to the same coin
from a higher self level maybe we had
the free will to choose this experience
maybe this is a chosen assignment for us
to figure out how much do we want to
evolve given certain circumstances given
certain experiences that we chose but
down here we don't know that you know
when we realize that there is a choice
there emerges a new reality there's a
different version of ourselves that we
can contact
and maybe there's even a future self
that knows that we have the ability to
choose differently which comes into some
interesting topics of you know parallel
realities different timelines being able
to Quantum jump with plant medicine I
would say the most I would describe this
um is that to me it feels like when you
go in you're really your reality on the
inside and the outside are somewhat
matching and then you go and do a
ceremony of some kind and then they
don't match up at all anymore and so I
call it like you just you're jumping
timelines a lot and it takes a while for
your reality to catch up with what
you've just experienced and now what you
know and what is embodied within you
because you've you've been there you've
seen it you've felt it you've cried
through it you've purged through it
you've you've really embodied that new a
different reality
um
so
it's probably the area of quantum
physics that I get the most confused
about is dimensions and timelines
um I mean I can regurgitate it but I
don't I don't can't see it clearly so I
would love for you to explain how that
all works and you know even perhaps in
that example what's going on
so I think for ease of understanding
this and for everyone watching it's easy
to understand the concept looking back
so in retrospect we can imagine
different versions of ourselves
throughout our lives versions were
slightly different we're doing different
things we're feeling a little bit
different maybe when we had less
information about who we are we
understood a little bit less especially
if we're at this more awakened level now
there's a more there's a lesser awakened
version of ourselves that we can
remember that reality is still real so
we can imagine what happened when we
were at the fork in the road that made
us take certain choices and go down a
different route we can say arguably that
those versions of us still exist
and perhaps if we hadn't made the
choices to take us where we are today we
would still be that version of self so
we can play with this a little bit and
think it's like an experiment
what if they do what if those versions
of us are still alive and well and
they're going down a different route
experiencing a different fate of their
own maybe we experience an ultimate fate
in this lifetime but there's different
routes in order to get there maybe
there's different timelines where we
have more or less bumps in the road more
or less challenges where we awaken
slower or faster experience different
frames of Consciousness along the way
meet different characters operate with
different frequencies and mindsets
ultimately to get somewhere so maybe
point a and point B are the same in
between what's occurring simultaneously
are different realities in which were
these different versions of ourselves
operating under different mental
conditions all to get to where we need
to be
so to jump the timeline we have to
understand that that future self that we
want to experience it's also occurring
right now
in order to embody that future self we
have to think about what is that future
self doing what is it feeling what is it
thinking what reality is it experiencing
what frequencies exist in that Realm
what are we doing now that does not
align with that Future Self
and we start to think about really what
is our self what is the sense of self
that we believe defines us what is
permeating our entire world right now if
we consider the entire reality around us
to be a projection of our own
subconscious mind we have to start to
understand what is in the subconscious
mind what is it made of what are we not
seeing that is projected all around us
and that puts us into the position of
having to really reverse engineer a
reality from the standpoint that it's
everything in our mind that is
comprising our entire world so if we
want to Quantum jump we have to identify
certain factors currently at play that
we maybe don't want to experience so
maybe you want to jump into a reality
where we have an improved relationship
or you're more abundant or you're
happier in some way or you're healthier
so that means you have to be forced to
think about what made you unhealthy or
what made you unhappy or what put you in
the place right now where you want to
change those things now you're
simultaneously operating in three
different observed observed States
you're seeing the present moment you're
seeing where you once were that puts you
in the present moment and you're
thinking about where you have to be one
day which means tuning yourself to a
whole different reality
and you're actually existing in these
three different standpoints of your own
Consciousness now your Consciousness is
really just one one vessel it's one Soul
frequency which exists outside of all of
these three third dimensional
experiences but in order to Quantum jump
you have to sort of get to that
transcendental state where you realize I
am not this that I currently am I am not
my past but I can be whatever future I
want to experience when I really jump
onto that timeline and this is what
emerges from this you know Quantum
creativity standpoint
that you can really play with your mind
tweak your thoughts fantasize about a
totally different reality based on your
different thoughts and your ability to
side with a different version of
yourself which makes you dismiss certain
things in the past which puts you into
the present moment of deprivation and
resistance and that puts you on a
totally different timeline going forward
many people have experienced you know
totally
spontaneous manifestations of healing
miraculous healing different things in
their life where they realized oh my God
the past was never even attached to me
to begin with
they cure themselves of unknown maladies
they didn't know why they have
manifested them in the first place they
experienced massive shifts in their
relationships they have Miracles come in
in terms of money Finance their career
and all because they start to entertain
a totally new possibility
so with quantum physics the whole
premise is that reality is fluid it's a
very spooky Quantum realm because
observation is really what determines
the outcome so if we think about it from
that standpoint if we don't know what's
inner subconscious and yet our
subconscious is projecting our reality
then we need to learn to observe the
subconscious to illuminate the
subconscious mind and to make the
subconscious conscious though allow us
to understand what expectations are
creating our world
because we know from quantum physics the
when we change the expectation and the
observation the outcome also changes it
feels like
we can't see ourselves I can see people
like I I get it I it I see their
patterns it seems obvious to me I I pick
up on the frequency and like the whole
puzzle feels very obvious it's like a
kid's puzzle to me
but it doesn't feel so obvious then
there's always I'm like I wish I could
see myself as easily as I see other
people
so
it feels to me like where this mini
Universe of source
trying to experience itself right on a
micro level to the macro of supposedly
Source fractioning off to experience
itself low learn grow and just know
itself like that's our own little world
too like everything around us is
informing us of us is this an accurate
assessment
I think that's beautifully put that's a
very enlightened aware of realization
about how the entire universe is a
reflection of you of your experience of
course there's more to the universe than
we can see but what we're experiencing
in our own Matrix of our mind is a
reflection of ourselves this is why when
we change certain aspects of ourselves
or we see ourselves more fully
everything seems to transform and very
quickly because we're just becoming
accepting and aware inner observation
so the same thing goes for quantum
physics it all plays into the same
concept of what Consciousness is and why
does it even need to experience itself
you know in the whole scientific
Community this is a major question the
hard problem of Consciousness what does
it need to exist like what's the point
yeah Consciousness is this thing that
has a very transcendental nature it's
truly a cosmic Enigma right why does it
need to know itself it's this substance
that makes up all things that lives
within every animal every tree our own
observation within the water every
single thing is alive and it's operating
as one with this Cosmic mind
so the only feasible answer is that it
really needs to observe itself it needs
to learn through interaction with
everything else what is the point of
existence what is the beautiful Harmony
of coexistence what does it mean to love
what does it mean to go into the
experience of completely being as one
with everything else
and that beautiful experience of Oneness
is what we can experience when we detach
from the separateness of I am my own ego
and everything else is somehow a
separate construct it's really not if
you are Consciousness then we have to
come into this awareness that we are
just the same thing that everyone else
is made of literally nothing is
different
which forces us to think totally
differently about all things
where does uh where does religion fall
into all this because it feels like
there's been a lot of Wars over that it
feels like oh yeah they're very divisive
and judgmental even though the whole
thing is about love each other it's like
except for if you believe this then you
have to feel bad for them because
they're going to hell it's like where
did religion come into all this religion
was a Divide from the truth of the
essential Oneness that originally
existed it was created by mankind in
order to create this Matrix construct to
teach a story about Oneness while
keeping people fragmented away from it
to teach the story
it's almost like a test
right it's a test of what are you really
conforming to as you listen to this
story what is it teaching you about
yourself is it putting you in a state of
even deeper polarity as you learn about
these constructs and the deeper elements
of the story are you actually learning
love are you learning to unify are you
learning about Oneness and what that
represents are you just being stuck in a
in a distorted version of the truth
which is that everything is one how does
that feel within us when religion turns
people against each other we could say
that there is some Distortion coming in
technically religion should put an end
to all wars and it should make people
unified and result in Utopia right but
we know that's not happening which means
that this Clash this fragmentation is
just another way that Consciousness is
fragmented itself to maybe make people
consider do we need religion to learn
the one the one truth
and there are religions that are now
proposing a different reality like
omnism it's speaking to the fact that
all truths are the truth which is a
beautiful conclusion right we could see
truth
it's great yeah and it resonates really
with people who are open-minded who want
to really exist outside of just one
version of Truth and we want to see the
meaning behind all of these systems but
many are are archaic and many have led
to all of these wars and things that are
just putting people in opposition to
each other which we know doesn't really
represent why we're here so why just why
follow something that is putting more
oppression into
our divine creation
and that's so simple to just look at
everything like trying to understand
itself to question to lead to
questioning anything other than Oneness
with anything so that leads me back to
my favorite fun topic which is
relationships and it always feels like
those seem to be the most stirring so
what
why is it that relationships pull us
sometimes into our darkest places
intimate relationships
I think they're the most
they're they're most filled with the
lessons in our realities basically every
relationship it's the most telling thing
about yourself what are you really
attracting it's the best way to look in
the mirror Through The Eyes of another
person and how you're experiencing them
and how they're experiencing you
well right every single thing in a
relationship is part of the expression
of your own Dynamics with and within
yourself
so your partner ends up being your
greatest teacher they're either loving
you into loving yourself even more or
they're teaching you how to love
yourself to a point of maybe losing that
attachment and learning to attract
someone even better but every
relationship it teaches you to be
intimate with yourself if there is
intimacy present in the relationship you
can learn yourself to an extent that you
would not learn through anyone else
because through the partner you're able
to see the Divine mirror of
Consciousness you're able to understand
the polarity game within you what is the
magic sauce in that though because
you've got friends you've got parents
you've got whatever but like that
Dynamic seems to be the most triggering
so what stir what gets stirred within us
that makes it so potent it's it's got to
be the the dance of the masculine and
The Feminine which exists within every
single person it's an energetic Duality
that we need to come to reconcile we
both we everyone wants you know the
masculine feminine within them to meet
because if that were to be a harmonic
reality within us we would have the
dream relationship we would understand
what it means from the feminine aspect
to feel to experience the soft warm
energy of reality to be compassionate to
be empathetic to be loving to be
accepting receptive and to experience
the masculine reality which is much more
of a go-getter action-oriented a live
Dynamic Force which allows the two to
really come into Union there has to be
an invitation from the feminine to the
masculine to allow that exchange to
occur so men often are seeking a woman
to just play the feminine role while
they can continue to be very dominant
men but they also need to experience the
reality of the divine feminine within
them and so many women are you know sort
of taking a more oppressive approach
when it comes to like I want a man but I
don't know if I could have a man that
really loves me the way I need to be
loved because they are so dominant in
their own masculine energy that they
just aren't inviting the right man in we
have to be aware of what our energy is
actually saying a man needs to be
slightly on the dominant side of the
masculinity but have a really healthy
dose of femininity in order to be able
to caretake the feminine to be
responsive to feeling to know the truth
within his own heart to experience that
heart based kind Consciousness and not
just be this you know very cold warrior
in reality there's too many people that
are just acting out of this you know
strong-willed capacity to fight to just
live and survive same as women need to
be able to warm up to their feminine
Essence and be that warm container for
the masculine but at the same time have
enough will and strength to not feel
like they need a man to Define them and
so it's when a woman can hold her
boundaries and know herself and have
that healthy balance in a man can that
we can invite those people into our
lives that reciprocate those energies
and put us into you know the perfect
state of Harmony but many people enter
relationships because they want that to
be filled without them doing the work
they want to find a man who completes
them because they don't have enough
inertia and initiative in their lives
just like men want a woman to maybe to
be a doormat to just you know to take
care of his needs and while he doesn't
really want to put into the work to to
caretake her as well a man has his own
natural capabilities and it's something
that we all come into this world knowing
subconsciously where a man has
responsibilities has a drive has an
ability to be the guardian that a woman
needs to feel like she could be a woman
but arguably both need to First embody
their true Essence for the other to come
in so a woman needs to be a woman needs
to experience her femininity and her
power as the divine feminine in order to
manifest their relationship with the
Divine masculine it's when either is off
balance that the wrong relationships
come into play and then these power
clashes and fights happen in the
Dynamics between women who just have
that internal imbalance going on and men
who have that same kind of inner
imbalance both partners then try to
change each other try to you know fight
each other's external polarity
differences but really they're just
fighting the inner fight what's
expressed externally and just is just
the need to come into within themselves
and understand what are they really
missing internally where does a woman
need to be more of the provider for
herself and where does a man need to be
more sensitive to the emotional
experience so that they could show up
that way for their partner
that's how we really end the polarity
War if we can show up to our
relationships knowing that our partners
are just mirroring the reality that
we're experiencing and the less balanced
we are internally the more imbalance
we're going to manifest in order to
understand where do we need to heal
where do we need to recognize and see
ourselves which is often what we also
don't want people to see about us which
is the number one issue with intimacy
it's wanting to be intimate on some
physical level wanting to attract
Partners to make us feel better but then
not being truly intimate within
ourselves which means we're just going
to attract more people think that you
know more relationships is going to
solve the problem or showing up
superficially with someone is going to
solve the problem but really we all want
and crave that deep intimacy which only
comes through self-love the true
validation of ourselves and the
exceptions that no one can provide us
which allows us to then achieve the
Alchemy within the results in the
Alchemy with someone who's ready with us
I had this beautiful EMDR session where
I went into an experience that happened
and and watched how it how it went and
the choices I made and basically within
it the lesson I learned was that
when I was in integrity and when I held
boundaries and when I
took care of my inner child or higher
self
nothing in my physical reality really
affected me too much
on an emotional level because
I had chosen I was with the I was in the
best relationship I could possibly be in
and I was in resonance with my with my
truth with my higher self and it was
such a beautiful like example and
reminder of how when we are connected to
ourself when we're balanced within when
we're listening to our truth that um
that our outside reality isn't as
triggering it isn't as emotional it
isn't as charged because we've chosen
that relationship within so if you
choose the relationship with you and you
as the number one could you essentially
make any relationship work or is that
just mean that when you do that you now
come into a vibrational frequency to
align with someone in that same at that
same level
oh totally I think people who are really
self-aware do a lot of self-reflection
know who they are and have these really
strong boundaries they're going to be
way more selective about the partner
that they're with because part of coming
into this conscious realization of
yourself means very being very conscious
of who you share energy with seeing sex
is something very sacred as a conscious
field blending exercise knowing that you
take in your partner's energy so you
have to be very conscious of who you
give your energy to who you allow into
your field and what history are they
bringing into your reality too so it's
part of wanting to grow and Elevate with
someone what history you're bringing
into your reality say that I explain
that
when we meet someone we also start
entangling with their own history too
their their baggage their energy their
field it's supportive of every
experience that they've been through so
if we choose them we also choose their
entire past everything that's made them
who they are so if we're ready to
fulfillment exactly if we're ready to
embrace that we have to take on what
they're bringing the entire shebang the
whole package right so if I made the
choice I'm just kidding okay it's all
it's all good I I think the most
beautiful thing is is that the matter no
matter how challenging any one of them
is essentially actually the more
challenging the more lesson there is in
it the more growth the more more
expansion that's right but hopefully
love is more than just providing a
lesson something to learn from right so
many people are in relationships where
it seems like they're just struggling
they're trying to fix their partner
trying to work through issues they're
not seeing they're not recognized and
very often what we manifest is what we
experience in our childhood another very
important point to understand if we were
not loved if we were not seen we're
going to manifest a partner who does the
same thing who negates our needs who's
not there for us and we believe that
that is our reality that that's what
we're worthy of and so we become used to
that treatment and we validate abuse
because of our own internal abuse and we
also manifest our parents and other
bodies through our partners often
because we're still wanting to gain that
validation which we're never really
going to get so what we really need to
be understanding is how do we get to
that point where our primary
relationship is with ourselves and with
source with truth with the values where
we could totally be ourselves and then
we just won't let somebody into our
field who doesn't see us completely or
we're not scared of showing ourselves
completely which means that our reality
is going to be shared authentically with
our partner if there's anything that
we're hiding there's going to be this
dichotomy between you know our truth and
what we're experiencing on a day-to-day
basis and there's always going to be
disappointment because they're not going
to see us and we still want to be seen
but we also are refusing to be intimate
because without self-intimacy it's never
going to be a factor of play in our
relationship
let's talk for a second about the other
intimacy
um I'm just finishing up a book
um uh it's the Mary Magdalene manuscript
or the magdala manuscript about
um the uh Cult of Horus and Isis and Sex
Magic and it's fascinating uh have you
read it I did read it actually what do
you think
very interesting very interesting stuff
one of the really interesting points in
there was that we can experience our All
chemical Union either through a partner
or through ourselves and there are
different paths and many people believe
that there has to be this journey
through somebody else the meeting of a
Divine partner who catalyzes the great
inner growth journey and we learn all
the lessons through them but oftentimes
there has to be an inner Union first and
foremost in order to experience the
catalysis that needs to invite that
person in so really the lesson is that
it's all about personal growth it's all
about revealing Shadow and the elements
of ourselves that need to be transmuted
in order to hold space for that Divine
love that reality of true Harmony and
integration and we can't rush this
process really the alchemical union is
occurring through a lifetime within
ourselves everyone's going through it
everyone's learning the lesson of Love
everyone's learning this through their
Partners their friends and family and
their parents it's always happening sex
Alchemy is a really powerful potent way
to catalyze this because it often
involves the Kundalini rising and that
can be a a massive shift it gives you a
whole EMF field upgrade and usually
opens up third eye and the crown chakra
and you end up with more downloads
flooding into your reality and just
experiencing a totally different world
because you've been primed to receive
sort of this higher frame weights of
Consciousness you can see past the veil
once you've experienced that depth of an
interaction which quite literally you
know makes you experience a whole new
world right away
but that can't be sort of the goal that
can't be that we're just trying to
manifest relationship just to experience
that alchemical Union I think the focus
really needs to be on that inner
intimacy that reality of truth that
knowing are you embodying that divine
feminine spark or are you in that
masculine energy and all the elements
and qualities that requires to
experience Your Divine Union within you
that should be the priority yeah yeah I
100 agree in the book it does does
articulate how important it is that the
union is authentic right it's just this
isn't just like a vessel it's a it's a
it's a truthful Union where you both
have to be honest and vulnerable and in
integrity and in love essentially
um but it um but yeah I mean for those
who don't know it's basically like it
opens up with
um with the transmission from Mary
Magdalene about her experience and how
um she was taught in the school of Isis
uh that she to to how to
strengthen the car body which is
essentially the energetic body
um that is exists right outside of us
and that using sex and and an orgasm to
basically take the energy that is that
is happening down below and shoot it up
the energy up your spine through all the
channels through all the chakras to
essentially heighten that field and then
ultimately being able to manifest things
more in that state if you're thinking
about them it basically heightens
anything going on and anything that
you're thinking about am I getting that
kind of right yeah totally it's super
powerful and transcendental the
experience of having the whole chakra
activation the Kundalini rising and
feeling like you're quite literally as
one with the Divine it puts you in this
state that you have you're a Clear
Channel at that point you start to
receive more energy become very attuned
to your surroundings but I would caution
people who are really fantasizing about
this concept of the Kundalini Awakening
because many people who end up
manifesting the experience they have a
lot of after effects that they were not
expecting oh really a lot of people they
even try to create the Kundalini
Awakening through yoga through some
Force exercises which just stimulate the
energy and the opening of those chakra
points it can be very overwhelming a lot
of people experience some psychotic
episodes mental issues after going
through something like that lots of
energy lots of inner heat it feels like
your your life is just it's been pivoted
there's a before and after moment after
having that experience because you have
to be ready
yeah I recommend not not trying to
manifest it as one thing if it's
something that you've heard about that
is cool but you you don't know if you
should experience it let it come
naturally if there's a time for that
energy to activate it's going to
activate it might come in a spontaneous
burst it might come with a partner it
might come well it definitely will come
when you're ready and they're usually I
mean if we think about it as like the
intention behind that energy it's really
really creative life force potentiality
the reason we experience an Awakening
like that is to Prime ourselves to be a
vessel for our purpose for our mission
here it gives you the ability to receive
to really be a conduit of the Divine
which means that you need to be ready
for stepping into that mission if you're
still trying to not be on your path when
you go through an Awakening like that
you're going to be very confused you're
going to be like how can I turn this off
it was cool for some time had a great
orgasm but then after that there's too
many After Effects that's kind of the
reality that we have to understand that
you cannot play with things like this
this energy is highly powerful and you
have to really trust yourself to go
through the process on time and as it
should happen so maybe what I'm what I'm
hearing is that
there's nothing to do
life is doing you
in many ways yeah it's it's always if
someone wanted because if somebody's
still in there listening and they're
really curious about this stuff they
might be thinking you know they want to
figure out how they can
Elevate how they can
um raise their frequency how they can
strengthen that field how they can
um be Quantum Leap
um jump timelines
so is there anything to do or is it
purely having the intention that you
want to do that enough for the universe
to go okay
and then do you just let it go or are
there actual active practices that you
can put into your life that are going to
help accelerate things
well there's a lot of work to be done
within everyone but I feel like we could
learn to see that the universe is
teaching us what to do through
everything that comes into our lives the
lessons are all around us the teacher is
is you and life itself through
everything that you're meeting in your
reality there's always a lesson to be
learned and one of the most potent ways
to approach this is to just see that
every trigger is pointing you towards
something that you need to work on and
most of us we there's plenty of triggers
there's no shortage of you know things
to be looking at within yourself if
mainly it's something that's troubling
you with your relationships
usually the lesson is to think about how
do you feel about yourself and just
turning it from an external
obstacle that you're trying to meet into
something that you're internally
understanding what is the root of that
issue and that's really that's that's
the premise that I always try to remind
people is really this entire simulation
is a reflection of you this is a Divine
mirror of Consciousness so when it comes
to anything there's a source that exists
within yourself with health issues it's
a very you know very good way to look at
this because every problem has a
psychosomatic root cause everything is
pointing us towards something that we
need to understand which has an
emotional and energetic basis
so we can think about something like a
headache for example as like what is
that actually pointing us towards that
we're experiencing or what are we
suppressing when did that headache begin
why does it happen what is the stimulus
and what is the underlying reason for it
we tend to be in this process of just
trying to achieve a better result a
better outcome which means the lack of
that pain or more of something that we
think we need in order to experience
more Harmony more happiness more
alignment and want to add stuff in which
I believe is a major issue with the
popular Law of Attraction manifestation
teachings many people they enter this
space spirituality because they go
through disappointment in life some kind
of suffering some feeling that they're
out of alignment they don't have what
they want they're in the wrong situation
at the wrong time and so they want to
manifest change so there's this internal
reality going on of where you think how
can I bring this into my life which I
think I need in order to be happier to
experience a better reality there's no
understanding or acceptance of the
reality that you're currently in and why
it is what you're experiencing and
that's what has to happen for the
manifestation to unfold there has to be
a coming to terms with where you are
right it's a it's a feeling of like I'm
exactly where I need to be and if I'm
not understanding that then I need to
resolve all the things that have
happened to me before that put me
exactly where I am
and so it's it's coming into this
alignment of like yeah everything is
happening exactly as it's supposed to
but if we're still not recognizing that
there's more inner resolve to be had
and that that brings us the experiences
and the lessons often through different
people through synchronicities as soon
as we set that intention it's going to
be everywhere the resources are endless
the videos are gonna be popping up on
YouTube the different advice the
different methods and everything but
more importantly it's listening to
ourselves
and choosing the values that we want to
espouse in our day-to-day lives if we
want to have integrity we need to
approach ourselves and everyone else
with Integrity if we want to be loved we
have to be loved for ourselves if we
want a world of kindness we have to
start embodying that kindness It's
really these simple things but so many
people are externally chasing some
reality which they don't even believe in
because they're not choosing to become
that way sure and so we have to make
that choice
got to be a match make yourself a match
totally a vibrational match
so then what's the ultimate what's the
ultimate point then
of
this individual
life itself
and does that just is that could that
even continue into what is the point of
it of it all because it could be more
macro like oh it's to
next make your next reincarnation
something the next step further or maybe
it's to
become a different entity that's not in
this reality maybe it's to get back to
Source like you know from from your
perspective what is the point of going
through the pain
all of the resistance to why it happened
to get to the point that you are the
awareness that shows the experience and
you can fully come into alignment with
the experience to dissolve the pain
that's what leads to the dissolution of
pain and suffering suffering is really
just the accumulation of pain that you
haven't observed and haven't come into
alignment with that's often what I tell
people pain is inevitable but suffering
is optional are we going to choose to
see the pain and acknowledge the
resistance and heal the triggers and go
into the Shadow and see everyone else's
expressions of ourselves are we going to
still keep denying that essential
reality that we know deep down to be
true and so there is no point there's no
destination I'd say ironically kind of
the destination is the point where
you're not seeking the destination
anymore yeah it's where it's just
business it's just everything is and
you're just happy with it being the way
that it is you come into that point if
we think about what would God be doing
what would God Consciousness be
experiencing a reality of total
acceptance peace and just you know happy
with the way things are even if there
are certain things that we don't like
this doesn't mean that we you know
ignore the bad things that happen in
life a lot of people they they come into
conflict with this awareness because
they think you know what bad things are
still happening to good people and
there's ugly things in the world and how
do we reconcile that
well we have to reconcile it by
understanding there's a reason for it to
be there's a reason why it's happening
and we may not be the cause or the
effect of that but we have to learn to
coexist with those problems and learn to
be the best solution that we can be
we're here to elevate the frequency of
the collective we're here to be the
carrier of that truth the more people
that come into this alignment the better
time it'll be for the entire Collective
but it takes everyone just being devoted
to what they can do though it seems we
are these small beings that are more of
an inconvenience to the planet like we
really could do so much good if we just
come to embody our purpose and realize
that let's not cause any more problems
for ourselves and other people we can
learn to be happy if we devote ourselves
to our own Joy to the pursuit of more
happiness through authentic expression
and through the knowingness of who we
are we don't come into more
contradiction with other people or
ourselves we don't cause pain for anyone
else we don't cause pain for ourselves
and if we think of it as really this
entire spectrum of frequency playing out
just for the purpose of us learning how
to elevate then it's realizing what it
takes to elevate
that just changes the game when life
becomes this enjoyable pursuit of more
like we do just curiously observing
curiously taking in more insight
learning how to live a more harmonious
existence we just dissolve that struggle
and coming more into alignment with that
truth of Oneness which changes
everything
hmm
thank you things just happening and
having the experience for the experience
if there's anything plant medicine has
shown me is probably that like they're
like that that's one of the good lessons
it's just things happening and it's just
to be experienced
and also what do we do with the
experience what does it change about a
world view what can we do to be the
change we want to see in the world
everyone can do something there's so
much more that we could be creating so
much more we could be doing I think many
people have these innate abilities and
tendencies and desires to do certain
things that we also repress so really I
see Life as it's art we should be
learning to create create with our
abilities learning to do different
things to express our superpowers and
her magic in different ways whether it's
through dance or singing or through
cooking or through sharing with other
people sharing what we're good at and
doing it in a beautiful way to just
light up the world with our potentiality
and exploring also that potential that
exists within us because so often even
children will have so many of these
abilities which are just shut down they
want to do certain things their parents
tell them they're inconvenient and
school deprives kids of the ability to
do that so instead we're just we're
fighting in this world where there's no
opportunity no portal for us to
experience Who We Are and that coming
into love really means allowing
ourselves to do everything that we want
to be doing becoming that parent for
ourselves to nurture the inner child to
give ourselves the ability to play to
dance to be happy to to do these things
aside from work and the mundane
activities of life
to learn what Joy is to learn to feel we
can experience the orgasmic interaction
with reality at large which is really
just learning to become attuned to
everything to you know wake up in the
morning to experience to feel the air to
breathe in alignment with yourself to
move your body in a way that feels right
to speak with people in a way that's
harmonious to you to do things and to
every little thing can be imbued with
more love but that requires presence and
that's something that people are really
at a loss for these days I think that is
the essential key it's presence because
what Consciousness is is pure presence
so the destination really could be
turned into just the point at which we
dissolve all the distractions into pure
presence of what is and what can be is
just more presence how can we be so
attuned that we're experiencing the most
out of any situation how can we
experience our bodies to the extent that
we're feeling every subtle feeling and
not letting those feelings grow until
there has to be an illness to be
manifested for us to understand that we
are our own teacher every subtle sign in
cue is just more cues for the from the
universe to observe more to feel more to
experience more that is really the
beauty of life to experience that
aliveness through every motion through
every interaction with the universe and
just that awareness of what aliveness
means
really puts us into the state of love to
love every feeling to love the reason
for everything to be just puts you in
then appreciation and gratitude and so
there is an escalation from the states
of the lower frequency reality of just
resistance anger frustration denial
shame fear blame guilt all of these low
frequency emotions to transmute them we
have to understand what's on the
underside of all those feelings and
States it's a reality that we didn't
know was meant to teach us how to
experience the exact opposite the higher
frequency dimensions of knowing that
that's all meant to teach us more love
we didn't get more hate more pain in our
lives to just be stuck in that pain
we were meant to align with better
outcomes by becoming more aligned with
what can be
in herself
wow thank you Gabby that was beautiful
and so it's like it's so simple but so
hard you know
and
um but if it wasn't then it might not
feel as good either when you finally get
to the other side of challenges right
um it's that contrast that really
brings it home and makes you feel
joy and peace and Bliss those are some
quick eluding but beautiful feelings
that you never forget and um that's what
it's all about we have to ask ourselves
how can we experience more of all these
feelings it's usually a reality that's
like out it's kind of foreign too we
don't necessarily know what it means to
feel that deeply and so what many people
are trying to manifest through things is
really the state of feeling more of
those true emotions to align with bliss
is not just to have things that you
think will give you Bliss but it's to
First experience the feeling that you
want to get you there so what if we
redefine manifestation from the
acquisition of things to make us feel
to acquiring the ability to feel the
feeling which will get us to where we
want to be you think the boat's Gonna
Give You Bliss
it's like no what if it's a you think
it's a boat like no it's not it's
actually a go-kart you know or it's a
it's a it's a it's a house full of
plants you didn't know it but it's
totally different delivery than you
could ever imagine and if we just ask we
just embody the feeling and know how we
want to feel and feel it then the
universe delivers what it is that's a
match to that
right on exactly yeah well it's a long
road for all of us but it's beautiful
and the joy is in the journey that's for
sure
so thank you for teaching and teaching
us so much you're I can't believe that
you're 23 right almost
um almost 23. yeah
you're so far out of the curve it's just
crazy but
um grateful for that so so good to get
to finally meet you and I'm just like
such a kind of work in your messages and
for those who haven't been introduced to
you they will be they will be they will
be glad that they have and they get to
enjoy you from now on because it's um
some of the simplest greatest
heartfelt messaging that I feel like is
out there so thank you so much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button